hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lane waifu
and we are at episode 143 of hunter
hunter and i simply do not understand
how i went from episode one to here but
you know what let's not think about it
for now
instead we're going to look at this
picture of a panda and question why the
panda is
jing no really why is jinga panda in the
opening of 1.43
a runoff vote's happening and i guess
i'm confused as to why people are voting
for jin because he's not there
and why more people aren't voting for
biscuit i mean
biscuit honestly i think biscuit could
be the best choice for the head of the
hunters association
she's fair she's sort of kind sometimes
and she's great at massage which is
really all the reasons i want someone to
be the head of an association that i
am a part of any association anyway
episode 143
if it had a theme was one of rules
miscommunication
and cruelty oh and hisoka confused as
hell about what to do
the thing i still don't fully understand
about something is how something talks
tequila with eyes and how
hilar knows the difference between alaka
and something given the differences
the similarities i mean when when
something has eyes
something is alaka but something calls
kiwa kiwa when something is
something i really don't like that that
sentence made sense i am
absolutely right in my view kiel was not
human i've been saying this since we saw
his spear hands in the first arc but let
it be known that the fifth rule the one
to do with killua has to do with actual
siblings it must
surely truly because kiwa has such a
protective streak about this particular
sibling and we don't see kilwa's
assassination techniques as anything
less than superhuman in a way that we
can kind of see the others
i mean illami he's just kind of high
those eyes like
whoa hello eyes i don't know about that
guy
really i don't know about illumi but any
dude that can go through a puffer jacket
stage has to be human
because no one no no no
self-respecting alien is going to like
wear a puffer jacket and to my mind it
makes sense that illumi is just trying
to edgelord his way through life why
because he looks like he's trying to
edge lord his way through life his
dislike of alaka and his fear that
alaka's going to kill everyone while
dealing with gone is strong
but only a few episodes in we've managed
to undercut his primary reason for
chasing keelah i don't want to say the
clarification if this mini arc was
underwhelming but it's somewhat an
underwhelming conclusion
it's sort of in the same vein as having
hisoka talk to camera which he did today
as if he were
in an ad on assassination which is great
from a visual perspective but because we
knew it was hiskey going around killing
everyone it added nothing to the
narrative and added nothing to the
overall visual energy of the piece
if anything that moment slowed the scene
down slightly and i didn't
really like the chat to cam on its own i
could have seen hiskey's moment being a
really good ad for the episode to be
honest but put it in this context and i
was less than entertained by it despite
my obvious adoration
of all things he's okay there are a few
things happening in this arc that show
us
we're trying to finish it up quickly but
because of the
increasingly long arcs that have
happened there's a sense of narrative
whiplash
in the past information would be given
and we'd have time to come to terms with
it but now the manliest man whoever
manned the bigly strong man with the
expensive chin is dead and i never
really understood what was going on
beyond the black guy being like yeah
they're both stupid and this is
dangerous
in response to their political views i
guess what i don't understand is what
kind of hunter any of those three
are or were and maybe i don't need to
but with most hunters up to now i've had
a sense of what it was they were
interested in
all that they could do before they died
but this guy the one who died on the
phone to the water bender i've forgotten
what his name is
and i've been watching avatar i'm sorry
uh he was like old girl from the
simpsons just saying oh
my wife is gonna kill me please buy
something look i'll pay you to buy
something please can i use your name
i guess the thing that surprises me
about it is the idea that hisoka
bothered to do it himself
i don't know who else would have illumi
really only has hisoka to do anything
useful but
at the same time is this situation that
hisoka has created really
useful to anyone as he arrived at the
building i said under my breath oh
hiskey's bored and it really strikes me
as a boredom kill not a strategic kill
what is it that hiskey stands to gain
from this illumi is on a watch list
hisoka is not at the end of the day i
suppose hisoka is trying to get the
ultimate fight but i suspect his own
emotions around what that
is or what that looks like or how to get
it are confused because killing alaka
would have got him
an ultimate fight but first between
kilwa and
himself and then illumi and himself but
is it
the ultimate fight is gone still going
to be the best fight he's ever had
i'm not sure and i'm not sure he is
which was the most interesting thing
about the situation to me hisoka's goals
and motivations are fluctuated
throughout the whole series and i find
it odd that so close to achieving his
goal of fighting gone he's not helping
that outcome occur
i'm even more surprised that it seems to
be a result of friendship with illumi
and care of kiela
cutting his way through everyone seems
to be a pastime that he's taken up to
release tension but not in the same way
as it did during the hunter exam so
maybe everyone has grown in some way to
be honest i'm not sure if it's growth or
inconsistency but now that a number of
people are dead and alako's on route to
gone
while kilwa has made a point and
teradine is dead
let's take a look at 144 because it
feels as though
hisoka killing teredin was
just to speed up the arc rather than for
any internal motivation and that's
yeah 144 and we have to love our
heartfelt speech don't we
i mean we don't we don't but it tugged
at my heartstrings in a pleasing way
leorio explaining how he felt and what
he wanted from the situation was really
all anyone needed to know
i like that this is the way we're seeing
leorio and i like that this is the way
he's being used narratively within the
context of the show
he's always been the character with
passion so the passion is being used to
its fullest and unlike my issues with
hisolka this is possibly the mostly
audio-appropriate action and situation
for layout to be in
especially given his backstory there's a
solid understanding here that leorio
could win and the reason he would win
is the reason he's won up till now but
beyond anything
he cares about his friends either that
or the back and alien experiences he's
described beyond being a doctor i really
appreciate that this is a show that
doesn't hide from the reality of being
an adolescent my friend was squaring up
against horrific creatures and what was
i doing
jerking off and spending time with women
oh yes that's probably why leorio's so
angry at gon's dad i mean beyond all the
other reasons even in a situation where
gon could have had a normal life like if
he dies
his dad won't have even gone to see him
so he doesn't even get a normal
experience of death
and that really annoys the audio whose
bedside manner based on what he said in
that speech would actually be pretty
impeccable the idea that he won't stop
talking to people and that that behavior
is the thing
people often want someone who's gonna
care about them if they're hurt or
disappear that's what the hunters in the
room
need and that's what they want the
underground situation is equally
interesting and important because it
makes me wonder whether paris don was
the one who set up the ants to take over
in the first place
at the very least if anyone knew where
that guy was that the ants were looking
for it would be
paristan unless it is him maybe it is
and would that be so bad
no it would tie up a lot of loose ends
if i'm honest which we really need since
there are only four
episodes left so we'll take what we can
get right the idea that jing tried to
leave and cheatle that's dog lady's name
and i never took it in and by now you
know that i never will sorry cheedle
cute name but it'll go
but cheadle's attempt to force the end
of the voting is an unexpected shift for
major players here and it probably is
going to result in even more issues
because
it means there are less people around to
make sure alec is safe right
anyone who would have voted either
didn't know or didn't care about gone
and anyone who wasn't there to vote
either didn't know or didn't care about
the vote or has higher priorities and
thanks to the change in how the voting's
being carried out
the game that ying the tarot and paris
on play is being pushed into the third
act of the ark instead of dragging out
so while narratively it looks like this
was deliberate it also has the benefit
of speeding up the ark
and i have a lot of thoughts on this but
i'm not entirely sure how to clarify
them without seeing the rest of the
series so
we'll do that and then talk about the
pacing of this arc because i'm still
flip-flopping on how i feel about it one
thing i really appreciated was the fact
that everyone gone has interacted with
on any meaningful level was here to look
after him
if biski hadn't been out of the running
would she have been there i'm not sure
but i'd be surprised if she hadn't
simply abandoned the voting in order to
go
look out for gone i'm not sure without
illumi there
who or what is being protected at this
point so i'm interested to see what
happens with that because
i don't know how much danger everyone's
in if the wishing is undertaken
correctly
kilwa made it to gone and he's there to
fix things up and i guess the next
question is whether it works
and whether gone is grateful for any of
what's been done to help him
but that's something i need to keep
watching to know so that's it for me
we're getting close to the end now so
there are only so many more times i'm
gonna say click here
here and here make sure you get some
sweet treats or savory if that's your
preference
don't forget to like share subscribe and
i'll see you
next time